you might think this is gymnastics or
breakdancing or maybe even some form of
martial arts but it's actually a sport
called tricking and even if you've never
heard of it there is a good chance
you've seen it over the past ten years
or so social video platforms like
YouTube and Instagram have boosted
tricking spam base while fostering a
global community of trickers who are
constantly one-upping each other and if
there's one trick that best reflects the
sports rapid evolution
it's the corkscrew it's a one footed
tilted back flip combined with at least
one 360 degree twist even a single
corkscrew is tough to pull off so tough
that as recently as a few years ago a
double core where the trigger rotates
720 degrees in the air
was considered the physical limit of the
sport but pretty soon expert triggers
were landing double corks like they were
nothing
then came the triple corks and finally
in 2016 the world's first quad core but
since then only two other people have
landed a quad core on camera so is four
rotations the limit today we're going to
look at why a quintuple cork that's five
full spins combined with the Tilted
backflip is almost impossible to find
out what it takes
I got a crash course in tricking
fundamentals all in one motion exactly
spoke with some of the best triggers on
earth do you want to be the first person
to do a Quint if I had time to light
rains right yeah sure and talk with a
physicist about what separates tricking
from other acrobatic feats it's not that
your typical gymnastics kind of movement
it's not symmetric tricking has its
roots in martial arts which people have
obviously been practicing for thousands
of years but tricking as it's known
today has really only been around since
the turn of the millennium competitions
work like breakdance battles which means
the athletes are judged not only on
their ability to string together tricks
but also their style there's just so
many different elements that compose and
make tricking what it is
that's professional trigger Michael
Guthrie he was the first American to
land a triple course and in 2016 the
first person in the world to land a
quad-core a trick that is so hard to
pull off
he hasn't landed one sense as far as
power or difficulty goes this is the
pinnacle of tricking right now on the
quad core even the setup is tough it
requires a series of precisely timed
rotations that help the athletes build
the momentum they need to launch into
the air and perform an off-axis backflip
Plus as many twists as they can manage
all in less than a second you need
strength to maximize your height you
need coordination to maximize the speed
of your spin and depending on the
setting you might also have a spring
floor which buys you a few extra inches
of height and then of course you have to
land the thing which honestly looks
pretty painful
it's that back step back when you use
our arm step to get a better sense of
just how difficult this trick is Guthrie
met me at a gym in Redwood City
California to teach me some fundamentals
before we started he asked me if I had
ever done a back flip before like that
is a reasonable starting point but no
I've never done a backing up
so instead Guthrie decided to start me
out with something a little easier it's
called the scoot the scoot itself is
it's a setup for a trick it's a setup to
help us get more power relax let those
legs go over the head here and keep that
right foot off the ground just until the
end try to keep a little more control
before setting it down okay so yes there
you go and that left foot there you go
right yep exactly
now the scoop might not look that
impressive especially when I do it but
that's because it's more of a
foundational move it teaches novice
trickers the importance of being precise
with the timing of their movements and
it helps advance triggers build momentum
for more complicated tricks the scoot is
actually what Australian tricker Scott
Skelton used as his set up when he
performed the world's first triple cork
but for the quad core Guthrie needed
something more powerful what was missing
for you that was separating your three
or three and a half cork
from a quad finding the right setup so
when we were going through this episode
we had that moved the scoot which is not
necessarily the most powerful setup no
one has ever done a quad cork from scoot
so it had to be found in other words
Guthrie had to find something more
powerful than the scoot this search let
him do a more advanced set up move
called the touchdown raids here's what
it looks like so what makes the
touchdown raise such an outstanding
setup to help answer that question we
called up physicist John de Bartoli a
couple of things that are at play here
you exert large enough forces on your
body while your feet are in contact with
the ground to produce a large torque and
to give you a large angular momentum and
then when you're in the air you decrease
your moment of inertia by a significant
amount and that will further boost your
rate of spin all right let's break those
terms down one by one
torque is just twisting force guthrie
produces it when his feet and hands are
in contact with the ground
the more torque he applies the greater
his angular momentum angular momentum
depends on how fast a tricker spins and
something that physicists call their
moment of inertia which is related to
the way they position their bodies
around the axis on which they're
spinning now these concepts can be tough
to visualize on a trick or at least at
first so let's start with a more
traditional example a figure skater when
he draws his arms hands feet and legs in
towards his axis of rotation it
decreases his moment of inertia and
increases his rate of spin now let's go
back to Guthrie what makes the touchdown
rays so powerful is the way it allows
Guthrie to first sweep his limbs far
from his body and then pulled him in
close right as he's launching into the
air it's a little like the figure skater
except sideways and without the skates
plus Guthrie is actually rotating around
two axes one for the off-kilter back
flip here and another for the spins here
and when you think of it that way
tricking sounds a bit like gymnastics
which it
but there are some important
distinctions as well what is it that
differentiates a move like the corkscrew
which is a pretty typical move in
tricking from similar maneuvers in a
discipline like gymnastics my impression
seems to be that gymnastics is more
about symmetry of movement tricking
seems to create the illusion that the
laws of physics are being bent by using
things like asymmetric movement and and
just really non-conventional ways of
moving the body remember how the
touchdown raised let's go three gather
angular momentum it also allows him to
start twisting before initiating the
cork which means that when he does take
off he's all ready
spinning compare that to a similar
maneuver in gymnastics the quad twist
here's footage of the first one ever
recorded in competition now the setup
for this trick is a series of
symmetrical back handsprings but here's
the catch those handsprings totally
linear unlike with the touchdown rays
there is no rotation around the axis
running through this gymnast heavy feet
so he doesn't start spinning until right
as he leaves the ground only once he's
airborne does he really start to twist
and then there's the landing gymnasts
lose points if they don't stick their
landing in a square stable position on
both feet but triggers triggers can land
any number of ways in other words there
is a flexibility in tricking that allows
athletes to explore more dynamic
movements than you would find in a sport
like gymnastics and that flexibility
could be what enables a tricker to
graduate from a quad cork to a Quint and
that trigger might just be this guy my
name is Alexander Anderson and I'm the
most consistent Clarinda game remember
only three people on earth have landed a
quad cork on film the first was Michael
Guthrie he's only landed at once the
second is Japanese tricker show sate you
Emoto he's landed it a few times and
then there's Anderson how many quad
corks have you landed I think I've
landed like maybe a little over 10 or
something what sets you apart why can
you land it so much more consistently
- twice on the way up then I used the to
twist coming up and then once I reached
the top I start twisting for two more
coming down it happened so quickly it's
hard to say whether Anderson is spinning
faster jumping higher or both but either
way he's pulled this off more times than
anyone else on the planet do you have
any goals in terms of trying to hit a
Quint yeah of course I do think it is
possible aim but I just don't think it's
a possibility yet when do you think
acquit will happen I think in between
like five and like seven years maybe to
be honest it might take even longer than
that it took Guthrie almost eight years
to graduate from the triple cork to the
quad and every tricker we spoke to said
that going from the quad to the Quint
would be significantly harder but if
someone is going to pull it off it's
clear what they'll need to work on the
first thing is more height which is the
kind of thing an even bouncier spring
floor could help with but even more
important might be increasing their rate
of spin there are two ways that the
tricker can hopefully achieve this one
by providing more torque on the body
during the moment when the feet are in
contact with the ground and by providing
more of a dramatic larger before smaller
afterwards change in moment of inertia
in other words triggers are gonna need
to find a way to squeeze even more power
out of their setup move for something
like the touchdown raise that means
starting with their limbs even farther
out and we're tracking them even tighter
around their axis of rotation another
possibility is that no matter how they
move their bodies the touchdown rays
just won't be powerful enough maybe like
with the quad triggers training for the
Quint we'll have to develop an entirely
new set up move but until they do
remember that what triggers like Guthrie
and Anderson are doing is already almost
impossible